thank you
[Music]
do you guys still use venmo at Cash app
for everything I still use them all here
in there do you remember when they said
that we'd have to pay taxes on the ship
did you change anything no yeah I did
actually I changed the uh uh amount and
then I made every post private not
saying it for sure works but I'll never
send anything it's like over 600 bucks
as well I'd rather break it up uh and
then even when uh somebody has to pay
you something that is a loan I have to
make sure that they write that that is
in there yeah in the memo
and same with like if they're gifting
you something they have to write the
real thing now they can't just [ __ ]
something that is like within whatever
the parameters of that [ __ ] is
because because I get it but at the same
time I'm trying to avoid it hey repeat
after me government by the people for
the people
that's why the IRS now wants to know
about every single one of your cash app
or venmo payments that are above six
hundred dollars what about Zell did they
say Zell was kind of like a
but depending on dark money what was
that again Bart something trillion
trillion how many trillion yeah I don't
know above three yeah but I can't
account for I don't know I don't know
what they'll they can only count for 30
of it but uh but above three trillion
dollars it was what eight
six
so wait does that mean that you have the
responsibility to report your
transactions yourself and they're not
able to see it you're supposed to tell
them if you move more than 60 but they
can see it too right I think you'll flag
I think actually anything over 600 will
flag and ping them immediately okay so
it's like that thing where like hey how
much do you owe you tell us oh you're
wrong that kind of thing but just with
this now or it's probably like you know
when you go to the bank you can't
deposit more than 10 G's or else they'll
like have to yeah yeah and deposit but
they won't tell you that they're pinging
the IRS
yeah yeah damn we're just up to yeah
we're just claiming at the end of the
year but dude no your government
represents you [ __ ]
they're not they're not against you but
they they want to help you hey everyone
needs to pay their fair share right of
course
and that's mainly to stop people from
like using venmo and stuff for like
employment payment right or is that just
to I don't even know what the [ __ ] like
what do they say the reason is like well
I mean they they got a what 40 000 more
agents over covid during that time
because I think um one crypto and
digital currencies and all that they
needed to like hurry up and be updated
on that space because the government
wants a piece of every transaction that
goes down and if you break it up does
that loophole that
yeah but it red flags your account so
like like there since um so there's
something called The Wire act back in
the 80s right if you uh it was supposed
to be for drug dealers because in the
80s like all the Cocaine Cowboys and all
them they were dumping like hella cash
into different bank accounts moving it
so the wire Act is any anything over ten
ten thousand dollars cash it gets uh
like reported so then the IRS is like oh
you've been making a lot of cash
deposits like that's weird you know
so what some people will do is to avoid
that they'll come in and they'll be like
3 000 here 5 000 here it'll add up to
ten thousand but you still can't do that
because then it's they'll still track
how much you know you're putting in Cash
Wise and then they'll be like that's
awkward
so like all these things it's to it's to
basically inform the government like hey
you're you're having all these weird
cash transactions
and you're doing something Shady okay it
says here the new rule only applies to
payments received for goods and services
transactions meaning that using venmo or
PayPal to send a loved one a gift like
we were talking about pay rent or
reimburse a friend for dinner as
excluded so like you were saying about
putting the memos that does help but
also
um it's also excluded if you uh sell a
personal item at a loss that make sense
so there's no capital gains on it yeah
yeah yeah yeah so like if you bought a
couch for 300 and sold it for 250 like
ultimately the main thing that they want
to do is tax employable income and so a
lot of contractors have been using
things like PayPal Zell venmo and stuff
like that in order to like bypass the
normal and traditional ways of
documenting taxable income yeah that's
basically what it comes down to
but it's also just like the way people
send money now just so easy and
accessible it's so easy yeah it just you
don't have to because before to accept
payments for your card for a while it
would only be through like like apps
like striper the square or something
it's also include a convenience or
service fee or charge or something like
that exactly yeah no they're just making
it honestly more creative for people to
do other creative things like frankly
because it's like oh cool well now I
know you're doing this so I'll do that
so it's like oh like Millionaires and
billionaires they all know like oh well
I could just borrow against my own money
and then I'll take you know that that's
what they mostly do yeah they just live
off of loans that they got from their
own collateral so like okay cool well
you know instead of you pay me through
this way now we'll just figure it out a
different way happens every [ __ ] time
yep yeah it says straight up that for
the 2022 tax year the IRS is going to be
able to cross-reference both our report
and yours so it's that same thing like
taxes where they already know how much
you're supposed to pay but let's see
what you say yeah
so they know what you did on vimo but
let's see what you say yeah I only get
haircuts on venmo so go ahead which is
because those [ __ ] they ain't
trying to get taxed on their income yeah
what's the most you've paid or received
through Ved mowers though less than 200
bucks really for a service not something
like rent coverage or something like
that yeah for me it's just in history
yeah I don't think I've ever paid more
than 200 bucks on anything no way I get
a lot I get people pay me through like
packages sometimes right like yeah
people pay like a month worth of
training yeah so I'll I'll log it though
like it's just not I thought that could
be a couple Grand yeah exactly you print
it out and you have to show your
accountant and then your friends like
troll you with the [ __ ] they've got
eggplant with the spark with the calm
and then there's like a sushi with the
Chopstick we used to put all kinds of
dumb [ __ ] in those memos yeah but then
even we we did a story a while back that
people who were messing around saying
like something about Syria got their
whole like thing flagged and couldn't
move any of their money their account
was frozen dude the early ages have been
well I remember like if I like somebody
had to pay me or I would request it and
I'll name things like butt sex yeah
but now it's like butt sex is it it's
income so I gotta protect it
you have to be like oh is that
prostitution yeah income somebody got
something from it so yeah it doesn't say
so far Zell is not included in this
article see that's what everyone keeps
saying venmo and PayPal maybe because
Zell is attached to a bank yeah because
it's bank to bank so it's already been
documented yeah right
Sophia on-ramp
and the banks are run by I'm just
kidding but that's why I kind of like
Zell sometimes because it's just easy I
just put the person's number in and then
Zell is really cool yeah it's but again
that's already you can't really lie
about that later right because it all
goes in the same place anyway it's all
in your [ __ ] your uh statements at
the end of the month straight up even
though I'm seeing this on camera it
doesn't matter what I've been with
somebody for I'm always writing things
like food
I like I will never even if it really
was first even even at the barber shop
or whatever the [ __ ] I don't I don't
venmons do like haircut really I'll just
put things like like an ice cream Emoji
if I put food and if I want to deduct
later it's way easier but that's the
problem though even like for example
like the barber shop right
um because they're taking venbo they're
not giving you an invoice for it
so you can't deduct off of your expenses
and back it up I mean you can you can
say that but if you get audited then
like there's issues because it's only
from one side yeah if they're not paying
the taxes on as an employer you can't
use it as a tax write-off you know what
I'm saying my thought that they're doing
it like 100 100 but like I said if you
got audited you don't have the invoice
to back that particular transaction sure
I've been doing like
[ __ ] services
but you're in Nevada so you're okay
that's true it's free to give people you
have to get out of Clark County yeah I'm
in Clark County it's illegal in Clark oh
yeah blow jobs are taxed double there is
it legal in the county you're in Pahrump
we're all in Clark County all of like
all of the Vegas that we know of and
where people live is generally it's
really really tough for blow job
services legal in Clark County I was
okay there I heard that I put monk I put
monkey band wardrobe one time I was like
that'll be pretty funny
thanks for providing my monkey band
wardrobe
but then like you know I I really
I really would have mind paying taxes if
like I felt more trust in the people
handling our money like for example like
I see other countries and when you go
visit I'm like dude like they just have
better everything like roads and cities
and everything it just looks like it's
operating nicely and the dollars are
being used yeah and then here I just I'm
like where's the money going and you
hear so many instances of like
politicians like mismanaging the fund
and then like I don't know like it's
always like hey they promised to build
this [ __ ] Railway and those billions
of dollars and it just disappeared or
like there's always [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
like that so I'm like well I feel like
it's a it's a bad teenager that keeps
spending money on stupid [ __ ] why do I
have to like
trust them still that's how a lot of
people from like UK look at America huh
they go like they should look at your
[ __ ] road bro they should yeah it's
it's no different
than moving to Nevada because when when
you're when you live in L.A and you are
in your home and you go down the stairs
or whatever you look around your place
where the [ __ ] is the money I'm like my
place is worth how much money my place
worth 600 G's where the [ __ ] is the
money I live in like conjoined closets
no
I I live in that funny dude well you're
still living it it's funny to us now I
live in Nevada with this [ __ ]
and we look I everywhere I look I see
the money I'm like I see the money I see
the money I see the money because I live
in a big space I'm like holy [ __ ] I
can't believe how big my ceilings are in
[ __ ] it's because my mom just recently
is staying with us and then she was even
on the 215 whatever Anthony's yawning
she was like she's like I see why you
guys moved here like just like clear
like that that's I saw the two down
there yeah he just saw it she was like I
see so dude I do traveler friend told
her that I just had myself I just had my
sister and my brother-in-law for the
first time and they came to my house it
was the same [ __ ] they couldn't believe
it and then the whole time I'm just like
yeah well you should have married me Jen
you should have married
[Music]
[Music]